Go is a very ancient game.
It's probably the most complex game humans play.
There's more configurations of the board than there are atoms in the universe.
So, we've beaten Fan Hui, the European champion.
Now, we have to go and demonstrate we can beat the world's top players,...
...not just the European top player.
So, we're actually going to be playing a match in March against Lee Sedol,...
...who is the greatest player of modern times.
He has won more championships than any other player in the last decade.
And he has accepted the challenge to play AlphaGo...
...and we're quietly confident that again, who knows what will happen.
A human perhaps can play a thousand games a year.
AlphaGo can play through millions of games every single day.
That's at least conceivable that as a result, AlphaGo could, given enough processing,...
...given enough training, given enough search power, reach a level that's beyond any human.